It's freaking out.  All that banging
[wonder]
Yeah, I think it needs to see the light not metaphorically
Alright, so push it back in this direction and hopefully it flies out this way
[give] us a more like he's got to be able to see there's an opening there and like line itself up upon through.....which?
sprinkle some seeds on the ground
I'll leave that door open for a second and let's see if it leave the hallway
After all but the waves they make are super weak
He kickin' out
I'm loving this
this is henry from minutephysics. Hi there!
What happens if an immovable object meets an unstoppable Force is a popular question on the internet of course
Relativity clearly tells us that there is no such thing as an immovable object here's why
you make some my favorite videos on Youtube so..
you have a you have a Master's degree in theoretical physics right?
I do yes
this guy
occasionally i make Youtube videos.
Occasionally!
He makes videos where he draws about science stuff, but then he like kind of like augment them with visual effects
I think I know exactly how you did that at least I suspect
What do you think it is?
I feel like we have all those different arrows linked to each other to the sun in position
But lagging behind by some amount of time. Yeah, it'll move in and after like point one two seconds
It'll move it will begin its animation and catch up
you have a way of making these really complex visual effects look so natural
[when] I was watching I found myself realizing that you were demonstrating the principles
Very very well... like I felt myself understanding way better
Just because you're able to show it happening the way it actually happens.
[you] want to see that bird is still there
Oh, that's right there
It's going to sit there for hours until
nighttime or something they been like when the place is quiet
it'll try and leave somehow it is far from family it is not afraid 'cause there's too many activity
Hopefully, we just come into find no bird rather than a dead bird
Or we might just gonna say invent a net gun option B. I guess carmichael
He would prefer us [to] shoot indoors, but nick and I are rebels, and we're gonna go outside.
That's right Carmichael
Can't stop me. You're not my mom you don't tell me what to do who's ready for an unboxing?
Alright so here we go
oh... what we've got!
stream 900 portable ssd
960 gigabytes wow this is a 1 terabyte portable ssd. I think it has a USPC connection.
This is a nice looking hard drive
It's got rubber bumpers over baby buggy bumpers
what we got here?
Oh yeah, Solid-state drive
256 gigabyte Sd card I've not had a card that big ever in my life
I have this weird thing about measuring the advancement of technology
by whether or not I could eat it I can now eat
256 gigabytes ain't no thing. some point Hopefully I eat like 10 terabytes. That's what I know
I'll be really old. You know be calories on the gigabyte? a million.
It's physics. ask Wren
How many calories are in a gigabyte?
sick
Dude this is a 500 gigabyte hard drive. It's got little bumpers. Dude! all my data
Whatever. it's like Frisbee
I expand flash drives on-the-go mobile backup.So this plugs into your phone.
I'm going to take pictures on the highest quality settings
Sandisk big thank you for sending us a box all these cool things in it.
And guys we will tell you our Impressions and what we think of this stuff as we use it in our studio.
I hope it goes. Well. I'm sure it'll
What would you even call that a?
Nano Nano watt?
it's like what I say in the video is like a quadrillionth of aquadrillionth of a quadrillionth
this one is sponsored by folks
That do distributed computing you guys actually might be really good candidates for this
What is there people who do research
and they need to computational power instead of like just paying lots of money to rent out supercomputers?
They have made like a really really easy to install application
that you can just install on your own computer
and when you're not using your computer you make your processor and your gPU available
for them to do science research you're donating like your electricity bill to...
and you're like unused CPU time and GPU time
okay
to Scientific research
that's really cool!
The way it works is like if a computer finds a signal it's also checked by other computers
and then they even tell you like that
your computer was involved in finding this... they want to basically get people like you guys
And everyone who's watching to install this software on your computer
It's called boinc and then the particular project that I did this video on is called Einstein at home
And it's searching for Neutron Stars Super fast spinning Neutron Stars in the gravitational wave data
But there's a whole bunch of other projects on Boinc basically you install this one
Boinc thing uh-huh and then you can sign up for different projects to..
I see i see! So you can pick and choose what research compare does
yeah.So I have it set up to do this gravitational wave one
But there's a number of other things some of them are like biological like genome searching
okay!
or analysis and other.. there's other physics projects.
That's super cool.
[do you] thing the bird's still there?
Or you think it escaped with that open door ?
I'm hoping not a dead bird to clean up in the corner of the room.
I don't see it
Birdie!
Nothing is found
Yeah, the bird is smart and can figure it out after all.
[huh]
what do we got got a little portable 500 gigabyte hard drive
I asked for this 2 Terabyte one
well we also got a 1 terabyte hard drive.
I'll make up for it
Last but not least this will make Carmichael the most happy
oh
it's a 256 gigabyte
90 by 95 read and write feed this will be great for the next studio camera for the second channel
that will eventually get
One Day